[Music]
you must have noticed that there are
different types of shapes and curves
occurring in nature let's see if you can
name some of these can you tell me which
shape or curve this is yes this is a
circle now can you tell me what the
shape of Earth's orbit is is this a
circle no right it's similar to a circle
but elongated towards the side such a
shape is called an ellipse let's see if
you can tell me the next one
zeki and nora are playing a game of
catch look at all these paths formed do
you know what these types of curves are
called so this u-shaped curve is called
a parabola but not all u-shaped curves
are parabolas there is a property by
which a parabola is defined and we will
see that in the upcoming videos
there is another curve that we will see
it looks like this it has two curves
placed on either side of the axis this
curve is called a hyperbola
interestingly all these curves we just
saw have just one thing in common can
you guess what that is they all come
under a common category called conics so
what exactly does colleagues meets conic
stands for conic sections so what do we
mean by conic sections as the name
suggests conic sections mean taking
cross sections of a cone let's see how
to take a cross section of a cone but
before that can you tell me what shape
this is since it has two cones and this
line makes a right angle with these
circular surfaces this shape is called a
double right circular cone
yes two cones and this line makes a
right angle with both these circular
bases now let's see something
interesting when a plane intersects the
shape we obtain different curves in how
many ways can a plane intersect the
shape here one way could be horizontally
if a plane intersects the cone
horizontally that is at 90 degrees to
this axis we get a circle yes this shape
here is that of a circle how else can
this plane intersect the shape what if
we tilt this plane like this we get an
ellipse if horizontal then a circle and
if tilted a bit then an ellipse let's
continue tilting it a bit more if we
tilt it even more like this we get a
parabola and finally if we tilt the
plane like this we get a hyperbola so
what can we conclude here depending on
the angle at which the plane intersects
the core we get different curves but why
are we studying these shapes or curves
because we see these shapes in our daily
life constantly in some form or the
other let's have a look at each curve
individually most of us know about
circular shapes from wheels to currency
coins we can see many objects having the
shape of a circle we saw that the Earth
revolves in an orbit which is an ellipse
and many satellites that are launched in
space also move in an elliptical path so
just study the laws of the universe
understanding the ellipse is important
now can you tell me the shape of a
satellite dish this curve is a parabola
so why do you think the satellite dish
is parabolic in shape parabola has a
property to focus all the incident rays
on a single point so if we keep a
receiver at this point all the reflected
rays are focused here at this point now
can you tell me the shape of this
- this curve is a hyperbola can you tell
us why furnaces are shaped like this
tell us your answers in the comment
section below do subscribe to our
channel to watch more videos related to
conics we will launch them in the coming
weeks
[Music]
you